es la candidata nacionalista de extrema
derecha de nuevo enzarzada en una
segunda vuelta contra el manual macro en
su tercera candidatura presidencial ha
sabido reducir la distancia que la
separa del presidente de funciones pero
como exactamente ha remontado a esta
mujer de 53 años antes considerada
polarizador a su resto no recuperaré la
soberanía de francia en todos los
ámbitos lo que significa la libertad del
pueblo francés para decir por sí mismo y
defender sus intereses controlar la
inmigración y restablecer la seguridad
para todos tus
buscando distanciarse de las acusaciones
de racismo y antisemitismo el
saneamiento de su imagen comenzó con el
cambio de marca de su partido de frente
nacional agrupación nacional en el 2018
mientras que su plataforma anti
inmigración de línea dura tiene pocos
cambios le pega cambiado de enfoque
eligiendo concentrarse en la actual
crisis del costo de la vida agravada por
la guerra en ucrania
con los precios del gas la electricidad
y el combustible ya nadie se atreve a
ser irónico como presidenta bajar el iva
de todos los productos energéticos gas
electricidad petróleo del 20 al 55 por
ciento
otra ventaja para el epen fue el ascenso
de su compañero de candidatura de
extrema derecha y antiguo comentarista
de televisión eriksson moore cuyo
lenguaje incendiario y sus opiniones
extremas suavizaron su imagen
considerada antes de muy dura ha
relajado sus declaraciones en varios
temas ha abandonado su oposición a la
igualdad matrimonial y al aborto y ha
minimizado el flex it y su agenda ante
europea al hablar públicamente de su
condición de madre soltera y de su amor
por los gatos le pega transformado aún
más la percepción pública como más
amigable y suave algo que sus oponentes
políticos argumentan lo hace sólo para
aparentar